atena it is great to be here with you
thank you for coming thanks for having
me so I want to talk first about your
your founding story tell me about how
you founded your company yeah so um I
think I I always knew I loved startups
and because of that I I wanted to be an
investor someday because you can help
people start companies and not just do
it once but help many different people
um so I basically studied computer
science I really loved software I loved
building things and when I graduated I
joined a very fast growing company
called samsara um kind of saw that
company Skyrocket and hypergrowth but as
the company got bigger and also working
from home during covid I kind of
realized I wanted to spend more time
with Founders and uh I didn't have
enough personal Capital to be an angel
investor at that point so I ended up
raising a very small like micr fund 600k
um from one LP and I started using that
to write smell checks on nights and
weekends and I still remember I was in
my apartment in San Francisco and
everything was shut down so I basically
was talking to Founders from 6:00 a.m.
till 9:00 a.m. and then 6:00 p.m. till
9:00 p.m. and then all weekend uh having
Zoom meetings and even some of my
favorite Founders I invested in back
then they were in Switzerland or in
Paris or in New York and it didn't
really matter because we could just meet
each other online
and as soon as I started not only
investing but starting base case and
realizing that uh it was the
entrepreneurial aspect of figuring out
how I'm going to get in front of people
because I didn't have a background uh as
an investor I didn't have any firm name
on the wall to to show you know here's
why you should take a meeting with me
and I was just kind of reaching out to
interesting people or being connected to
to people through my network and as soon
as I I started writing those checks I
realized I loved it uh and I wanted to
do it full-time so basically spent six
months deploying that 600k building
relationships with really great Founders
and ended up leaving uh samsar in May of
2021 and raising my first fund then so
is there any particular Focus you're
looking on when you invest in people is
there any particular Industries or
categories or people you're really
excited about yeah so base case is a
little bit different and I like to say
uh I spend all of my time with Founders
before they're actually Founders so uh
unlike most VCS I don't really take
pitch meetings I am mostly talking to
the brightest engineers and maybe second
time Founders whose companies were
Acquired and sort of getting to know
them when they are just in the thick of
it whether they are just learning uh how
to adapt as a company scales many of the
people uh my year you know graduated and
joined a company like stripe or retool
and they've been there through like this
hypergrowth phase and maybe they know
that they want to start a company
someday but there aren't a lot of
resources for people who are still very
much early in their career um and
haven't left haven't decided to start a
company yet and so I try to get to know
those people figure out how I can help
them introduce them to maybe some of my
portfolio Founders to talk about their
journey and uh eventually whenever
they're ready to leave and start a
company I try to write the first check
in very cool now give me some examples
of these portfolio companies and what
some of your your favorites are and what
they do yeah so one example I'd love to
share uh is a Founder named ion and he
had uh started a previous company that
was acquired by G2 and he was leaving um
after three years of running engineering
at that company and while he was there
he was an angel investor uh as I think
many exited Founders are they start
writing checks into people and
supporting Founders and so we got
connected actually through Angel
Investing and through that I I got to
know this guy and I knew he was very
thoughtful about markets he was an
engineering leader so he's very
technical U but he was always really
good with people as well and after sort
of three years of getting to know him in
that context he called me one day and he
said you know this last uh last week was
my last week at G2 and I'm going to
leave and I think I want to start
something new and I said I want to back
you and he didn't know what he wanted to
do yet and I just knew from my
relationship with him that he was going
to build something and he was going to
do it big because he had sold his
previous company um didn't obviously IPO
that company and he really wanted to to
build something massive so I invested
and then we went and talked to a bunch
of customers tried to figure out uh
where in this sort of Market he wanted
to build and eventually he landed on the
idea the co-founder and raised a bigger
seed and that was was one of my favorite
experiences of seeing someone that I
invested in from truly the negative one
there was you know no idea just a human
and someone that I had a lot of
conviction in to then coming up with the
idea meeting the co-founder raising the
seed and now this company is in
production with a bunch of really
exciting customers and uh it's really
exciting to see what they do now back to
you in your fundraising Journey how did
you go from the 600,000 you were talking
about earlier to where you are now and
and talk about where you are now yeah so
um I was very lucky to have a great
mentor and a great first investor in
that 600k so um elod Gil he's another
very successful solo GP and angel
investor himself and it kind of happened
uh spontaneously where I was again at
samsara this amazing company but I felt
like I was missing something and I
called him and I said hey I'm thinking
about maybe transitioning to investing
um I had interned at Greylock and
another really great firm in the past
and done Sequoia Scout program um and
general Catalyst fund for students which
is called rough draft so I knew about
these like you know how to work at a a
major firm and then I I know elad who is
a sort of Angel solo GP investor and I
said what should I do I feel like it's
early too early in my career to like
fully transition to investing and I
don't know if I want to go join one of
these firms just yet and he said oh I'll
just give you you know 600k you can
invest in in your spare time while
you're still at samsara and I think just
having that sort of belief in me of hey
just do this and get started with it was
what I really needed to actually start
writing those checks and again once I
was in the thick of it and building
relationships with Founders I realized
like this is what I want to do I think
I'm someone who once I I jump into
something it's very hard for me to do
anything half ass so uh ended up just
realizing this is what I want to do
full-time and the the first fund I
raised was 20 million um it was anchored
by lot and was really lucky to have all
of those firms that I just mentioned
invest as well and then a bunch of
operators Founders investors um so you
know the founder of Dropbox confluent
air table um a firm and the best part
about working with these people is they
know how to build businesses and they
have really great networks um so I
really love sort of getting their take
when I'm talking to an entrepreneur and
saying you know can I introduce you to
this founder and they always have really
great advice and are able to help me
sort of 10 or 100x my network because
I'm just one person as a solo GP and
being able to leverage their experiences
and their networks is really helpful now
something you said that was super
interesting and like kind of unheard of
in the VC communities that you say you
don't take pitch meetings which is so
interesting so what is it about like is
it a quality is it a type of Industry
that makes you want to invest in someone
and think like you know there's magic
here yeah um I really think it's it's
quality and I I I will say like I
broadly invest in B2B software so it's
not like I'm meeting consumer Founders
or crypto Founders um but broadly within
the realm of B2B software I'm not not
sort of fishing for like great ideas or
you know I don't take a very thesis
driven approach to investing but I'm
looking for Quality so like grit is a
huge one that's why I really love
investing in second time Founders and
specifically sometimes it's people whose
first company was not a success you know
they maybe were Aqua hired or the
company didn't end up working but some
of the the best companies actually are
built by second time Founders who you
know come back with a a you know a chip
on their shoulder and they're ready
ready to go and do something and they've
learned from their previous experience
so I love meeting people like that I
also love people who are obsessed with
building like I'm an engineer myself I
still spend a lot of time building and
some of my favorite companies actually
are where I met the founder because I
was building something using their
software and I got to know them and uh
maybe had a a bug that I saw or was
giving them some feedback on the product
um couple of my favorite companies one
of them is subase which is a really
popular database the other is resend
which is a open- source API for emails
and so I've built uh different products
like email products um and using these
products I was able to meet the founder
and say hey this is really cool you know
have you thought about this or that um
and seeing the just response of Founders
when someone's using their product and
they're really eager for feedback that's
something that I I also really love I
love that is there anything that's like
this is an immediate turnoff for me I
there's no way I'm going to invest in
this I think I I uh I'm lucky because as
a solo GP I like to say
um I really have the privilege of
investing in Founders that I actually
want to spend time with and that's why I
I think I'm really good at what I do is
that I spend lots of time with my
Founders because they're just like fun
they're they're my friends some of them
you know were at my wedding
they they people that I've built really
deep relationships with and I say I'm
always sort of available I want to be
with them 247 and help them however I
can so if someone has a uh just an
attitude that maybe I don't get along
with like I don't have to really invest
in those Founders and I would say yeah I
more look for the positives in people
than the negatives but I get really
excited when I I just hop on a call or
meet someone person and I'm like I just
need to spend more time with this person
that's awesome it's always good to to
have that balance too just for for your
mental health um so what's it been like
as a woman to navigate in this
ridiculously male-dominated VC industry
have you faced any big
challenges yeah I think so when I was
raising my first fund uh the first fund
I raised was a $20 million fund and I as
I said I started raising it and uh was
anchored by elad Gil and then had a
bunch of other investors come right away
and I still remember about a week into
that I looked at my air table tracking
of the investors and there was probably
one woman um and I was like okay after
this week I need to only talk to women
um and underrepresented minorities in
Tech and that's what I did which I I see
all these fundraising announcements for
funds all the time and you you know they
have like the pictures of all their
investors and it's great and you know I
just named a bunch of uh Founders that
have invested in me as well and and you
know a lot of them are men but a lot of
them are women too and um I think it's
really intentional so after that week I
said I need to have at least 50% of my
investors to be women people of color
underrepresented minorities in Tech and
I lowered the minimum check size
historically funds have sort of a crazy
minimum like2 50k to invest lowered that
to 5K was the the lowest check and
because of that I actually started to
talk to so many more interesting people
that typically wouldn't invest in funds
and these are you know early career
product managers engineers at at
startups um who haven't really invested
in funds like this before again because
of the minimum but what I found is those
are the most helpful investors like I
I'll send my investor update every month
and I'll get sort of the this woman who
is is a early career product manager
responding and say yes I will introduce
you to this person at my company for
this event that you're hosting or one of
my favorite examples um I'm really lucky
to have Fiji who's the CEO of instacart
and she's phenomenal I'll send an update
and say I'm you know hosting a dinner
for AI leaders five minutes later
whether it's on a weekend at 6:00 a.m.
or you know a Monday night at 7 p.m.
she'll respond within 5 minutes and say
you adding in JJ who's our chief
architect who would love to join your
dinner so without a doubt the the women
and the the people that I typically
don't think would have made it into the
fund if I had stuck with sort of the
typical Norm of 250k minimum are the
people who are most helpful to me so
that's really something I've tried to
carry with me um so I I raised my next
fund which was 20 million the same sort
of uh investors and then now I'm closing
my next fund which is 50 and now have
transitioned to institutional Capital so
I think the the thing that I've tried to
figure out with institutional investors
is um yes I love having women who are
leading those Investments for for their
firms um but also like you know where is
that money going at the end of the day
and it's been really interesting to find
institutional Partners who have really
great missions and are working on some
amazing things that's what I was going
to ask about next is is what's the
future for you look like what's 2024
have for you on the horizon yeah so I am
very excited that uh I think Venture is
a game of just compounding Network and
if I think back to uh you know what
makes me successful today it's all of
the relationships that I built over the
last like 10 years um even going back to
you know college and and before that so
what I'm really excited for is the
relationships and the people that I've
been spending time with again who are
not yet starting companies this year
next year the year after you know
whether it's 6 months or six years from
now those people whenever they start
companies I'm hoping that I'm the first
call and I'm hoping that I can be even
the first person who believes in them um
and maybe even gives them the confidence
to take a step forward and say okay I'm
actually going to start a company now so
um I think the future of base case is
really creating a space again for that
negative 1 to zero of being able to find
people and help them figure out what it
is they want to do next connecting them
with co-founders getting validation from
customers on the idea that they have in
the market and then helping them hire
engineers and go build that's awesome if
you could give yourself one piece of
advice um the day before you started
your company what would you tell
yourself that you wish you had known
that you know now I would say lean
into what makes you you and forget about
what people traditionally do in this
role and that's something that's
probably taken you know i' started I
raised that first 600k almost exactly
three years ago it was like October 13th
uh was when that fund was typically like
was actually
Incorporated and I think when I first
started I looked at all the other
investors and I said okay you know they
take pitch meetings um you know typical
investor is meeting companies that are
actively raising they are looking at
decks and they're asking really smart
questions and there are a lot of great
investors that do that and I thought
that that's what I had to do and it
really took me like a couple years to
realize actually what I'm really good at
which not a lot of other people are good
at is just finding great people and
building relationships and seeing things
in people before anyone else does and so
what I sort of realized over the last
two years is like whenever I do that it
ends up being a really successful
company
when I follow the typic you know
inv of meeting a that's raising looking
at their pitch deck meeting them for a
pitch meeting th those aren't as
successful for me and so I think the
advice that I give to other people now
is like think about like what what are
you actually really good at and you
usually it should be the same you know
what do you love doing and for me it's
just getting to know people and um
seeing them grow over time and there's
nothing that I love more than you know
know someone that I some of the founders
that I've invested in they're people
that I met in college and they're those
people that I met and then a year later
you know I visited them then when they
were interning at Facebook for lunch and
then a couple years later I saw that
they moved to another company like
stripe or retool and then when I figure
out they're working on something and
they say hey can I get your advice on
this I actually have so many different
touch points of them over time and
seeing that trajectory in different
people's careers is really exciting for
for me and I think I like to be there
and just a friend whether you're
starting a company or not and usually I
think that pays off for me so that's one
thing that I I really enjoy doing so you
were saying how a lot of the people who
you invest in are friends people who've
been to your wedding how do you separate
the personal and the professional there
and do you have any boundaries or or
rules you live by I think one of the the
things that I love about sort of BC and
and being a solo GP
is I can play different hats at
different times in a company's Journey
so for example when I invest in a
Founder who I'm writing the first
check-in oftentimes I'm the only checkin
so I'm kind of the only person for them
and I need to be a support system but I
also need to keep them accountable and
so that might look like you know you're
coming over to dinner at my house on a
Friday and then the Saturday morning we
were having a working session about
going and talking to customers um but as
companies skill and more investors join
the cap table I really love to see how
that relationship can change and maybe
that means that I'm more helping out
with intros to Engineers to different
candidates to customers and when someone
comes in and joins the board I never
take board seat so I don't feel like I
have to um sort of take control of the
Founder's vision in any way but I think
I in any relationship I have in life
whether it's you know my amazing parents
my husband who's also a Founder um I
think Honesty is is super important and
I think having that friendly
relationship with Founders actually
helps me be more honest and uh
oftentimes I find myself saying things
and giving feedback that no investors
would give because they don't actually
care that much you know it investing uh
is sort of a game of portfolio right and
you have maybe one or two companies in a
portfolio that end up working out and
for that reason it can be if a company
isn't working then maybe it's not worth
saying anything I think for my Approach
is if this is my friend I want to give
them the honest feedback and I'd rather
them hear it from me than to hear it
from anyone else so uh that's the
approach that I take I think I'm a very
straightforward honest person
and um I think having a good friendly
relationship with Founders actually
helps me do that better and one last
question for you and this is a lofty one
so you can take a second what would you
like your legacy to
be I think
when people ask me about
um you know goals with with base case or
or why I do this I think part of it is
you know investing in great companies
and it's one thing to have a really
phenomenal track record and to be an
investor in you know amazing companies
like instacart you know which just ipoed
it's like very exciting and all the
investors are really
happy for me it's not enough just to be
an investor in great companies I want to
be a someone that those Founders say you
know I am so thankful and I couldn't
have done this without Atlanta support
and she believed in me and she sort of
gave me the conviction to go into build
something and I think the the goal that
I have with base case is to you know
give people confidence in themselves
that they can go and build something and
give them all the resources they need to
go and do
that so if I can just inspire people to
to go build and give them the the sort
of push to to you know jump off the
diving board um I think that's what my
goal is well that's a fabulous way to
end so thank you so much Atlanta for
being here I really appreciate it thank
[Music]
you